die Rankings der besten Business Class
der Welt sind sich nicht immer einig
manchmal ist es Qatar manchmal Emirates
Japan und Singapur Airlines steidigen
auch gut ab aber welche ist nun wirklich
die beste um diese Frage weiter zu
klären testen wir heute die Emirates
Business Class auf meinem Rückflug von
Dubai nach Frankfurt viel Spaß und damit
Leute einen wunderschönen guten Morgen
aus Dubai es ist 11:15 Uhr ich fliege
heute um 15 Uhr zurück nach Frankfurt in
der Emirates Business Class mein Fahrer
steht schon unten bereit der ist
irgendwie schon seit 20 Minuten da ich
stand unter der Dusche und dann hat hier
Terror gek
na ja überpünktig ist hier eigentlich
nie verkehrt also ab runter dann geht's
zum Terminal ich glaube das ist hier
ziemlich cool hier in Dubai hat em mich
so ein eigenes Business und First Class
Terminal wie ich gehört habe das schauen
wir uns natürlich erstmal in Ruhe an und
dann geht's auch schon ins Flugzeug ich
wünsche euch viel Spaß mit einem neuen
Business Class Test mal gucken ob die
Emirates Business Class mit der von
Qatar Airways die ich auch schon
getestet habe mithalten kann und ja
nicht lang labern auf geht's runter viel
Spaß mit dem videor okay bye bye okay
Leute auf geht's ich hatte einfach room
number 420 aber habe ich ir wie total e
dann so einmal 420 Auschecken also room
than you hello
sorry
okay normal okay ext Terminal
businessp do
thank
you so Leute hier sind wir im First
Class und Business Terminal in Dubai und
ich check jetzt erstmal ein da hinten
ich glaub ich muss hier eigentlich gar
nicht hin weil ich muss ja auch nichts
abgeben na ja schauen mal my lugage
because small
so yes do okay thank you ihr wisst ja
Leute ich reise eigentlich immer nur mit
meinem Rucksack hier hinter mir deswegen
muss ich jetzt auch nichts abgeben gehen
wir einfach mal hier ein bisschen lang
und finden uns zurecht hoffentlich hier
ist zwar nichts los aber es ist trotzdem
verdammt groß smartgates self okay so
Leute vor mir kommt jetzt Security Check
ist einfach nichtich los kann ich
einfach durchrennen wä geil wenn das
immer so entspannt
wä Checkin habe ich geschafft hier geht
jetzt zu den First in Business Class
Lounges denke da bin ich richtig
eigentlich ein bisschen stumpf weil in
Frankfurt gab's ja keine reine First
Class Lounge aber hier gibt's jetzt
schon und den Hinweg bin ich ja auch
First Class geflogen od da konnte ich
halt nur in die Business Class Lounge
deswegen eigentlich wä es besser gewesen
wenn ich hier jetzt die First classass
Lounge mir anschauen könnte weil die
sind hier getrennt na ja man kann ich
alles haben ne so hier Business Class
First Class na ja ich geh mal davon aus
diese Business Class loue ist ähnlich
wie die in Bangkok damals von Qatar
Airways vielleicht ein bisschen
schlechter wir werden
sehen danke
[Musik]
danke
Alter wie groß ist das hier bitte es ist
ja fucking riesig
hier was geht ab so Leute ich bin jetzt
mittlerweile hier in der Business Class
Lounge man muss sagen die ist wirklich
verdammt groß also ich hätte niemals
gedacht dass man hier so viel Platz hat
also ich würde mich nicht wundern wenn
hier wirklich so 1000 Leute reinpassen
das ganze ist ein bisschen aufgeteilt da
vorne gibt's so Snacks und eher so
frühstückssachen und da hinten geht's
dann weiter mit Mittagessen und auch so
Nachtisch und auch eine Bar das schauen
wir uns dann gleich noch an ich habe mir
jetzt erstmal hier ein paar
frühstückssachen
geholt ja also auf der einen Seite
natürlich ganz cool aber mir fehlt ein
bisschen so der Charakter also da hat
mir die in Bangkok auf jeden Fall
deutlich besser gefallen ach so aber die
in Bangkok war auch Qatar Business und
First Class also wenn First Class mit
integriert ist macht sich das dann
vermutlich schon bemerkbar ich bin mir
nicht sicher aber kann sein dass es da
oben so Schlafkabinen sind für Glas a
krass hier gibt sogar ein
sparereichben halben Kil gerant wir sind
jetzt hier sind einfach die Toiletten
beheizt ich wusste gar nicht dass es
sowas überhaupt gibt also man muss
eigentlich sagen das ist hier ein ganz
normales Terminal nur es ist halt alles
umsonst gut da unten kann man auch
einkaufen das ist wahrscheinlich nicht
umsonst aber das ganze Essen halt alles
V free auf jeden Fall die größte Lounge
in der ich hier war für mich gibt jetzt
hier noch ein bisschen asiatische Küche
aber nicht so viel weil gleich geht's
ins Flugzeug und da gibt's ja auch
wieder essen ich finde der
Wohlfühlcharakter geht hier ein bisschen
verloren aber es ist nicht verkehrt also
ich will gar nicht meckern nur ich habe
es mir anders vorgestellt das stimmt auf
jeden Fall lol es regnet
einfach ich dachte gerade erst die haben
mir wieder so ein Wasserfall installiert
oder so so ein künstlichen aber das ist
echter Regen okay Leute ich bin raus aus
der Lounge oh meine airpods sind leer
wir fliegen eigentlich schon in ein
halben Stunde und ich wundere mich ein
bisschen dass wir immer noch nicht
Boarding haben aber ich gehe jetzt
vorsichtshalber mal hin B26 muss ich
okay und mittlerweile ist es echt auch
ziemlich voll geworden hier am Terminal
eben war ja noch gar nichts los echt
verrückt und das sind alles Business
Class Reisende und halt First Class also
schon ziemlich viele Leute die sich
sowas leisten muss man auch sagen weil
es ist echt ja gar nicht mal so günstig
ne und wenn ich jetzt kein Video drehen
würde wde ich safe economy fliegen es
sei denn ich habe genug Meilen
meinammeln geht ganz einfach mit MX
Platin könnt ihr euch gerne holen be
Link ich euch in der Videobeschreibung
kostet aber 60 € im Monat okay ich bin
eingecheckt da vorne steht auch schon
mein Flugzeug ich habe gehofft dass noch
geswitcht wird zu einem Airbus A380 weil
das passiert manchmal na ja irgendwann
machen wir das natürlich auch noch
[Musik]
also ich glaube das passiert h wirklich
nur einmal im Jahr dass es regnet oder
irgendwie total komisch ich kann es
nicht einschätzen auf geht's ins
Flugzeug ich bin mal gespannt ich freue
mich auf den Flug wird bestimmt wieder
super relaxing zweites Mal in meinem
Leben Business Class und ja hier steht
schon jaw okay gut einmal bin ich nach
Malle mit Condor businessass geflogen da
hat ich auch so ein verlängerten Sitz
aber eigentlich zählt das
nicht
mir ist dann auch direkt aufgefallen
dass ich in einer neuen Boeing 777 von
Emirates gelandet bin und nicht in der
alten mit der ich ja First Class
hingeflogen bin hier sieht alles und
auch die First CL Kabinen ein bisschen
anders aus ich muss aber sagen das alte
Design gefällt mir besser ihr könnt mal
eure Meinung in die Kommentare schreiben
und das hier war mein Platz
[Musik]
9f okay ich muss sagen WN man einm
geflogen ist der Unterschied ist
natürlich doch schon gewaltiger als man
denkt
[Musik]
ne so jetzt gibt's hier schon Champagner
yes Please thank
you thank
much okay thank you also auch hier ist
der Service natürlich bezaubernd Rost
auf einen schönen Flug zurück nach
Deutschland
ich werde damit nicht war mit dem Zeug
[Musik]
ne die aktuelle Temperatur im Flugzeug
beträgt
[Musik]
3° muss sagen ich bin immer so
fasziniert von diesen Kameras weil man
kann ja mal rechts rausgucken und auch
nach unten jetzt kommt das
[Musik]
mehr und sorry dass das Bild hier so
flackert das liegt nicht an meiner
Kamera sondern an diesen Lichtern hier
ist halt super empfindlich jeder
Business Class Reisende bekommt diese
Emirates neus kenzen Kopfhörer die
unterscheiden sich allerdings noch mal
zu den in der First Class dort gab es ja
die Bowers and Wilkins Kopfhörer die
dann noch mal ein bisschen besser sind
außerdem gibt es an jedem Platz
gekühltes Wasser und auch ein paar
softdinks die man sich halt durchgehend
nehmen kann ganz nice to have und es
sieht auch wirklich schön aus ich habe
mir dann erstmal mit dem Control Panel
hier ein Film rausgesucht am Ende wurd
es ein Avatar den habe ich mir
reingezogen war ganz geil also das
Entertainment Angebot an Bord wirklich
super es gibt auch richtig viele
deutsche Filme das Getränkeangebot
natürlich top es gibt jede Menge
Cocktails auch mocktails Bier was weiß
ich also man kann sich da oben richtig
zuschütten das Essensangebot auch super
es gibt verschiedene Vorspeisen
Hauptgänge und auch Nachtisch ich konnte
mir allerdings nur eine Vorspeise
ausfülen das war bei Qatar Airways
anders da wurde ich auch mit Vorspeisen
zugeschüttet essen aber wirklich top
werdet ihr gleich sehen sah auch sehr
sehr lecker aus es gibt außerdem eine
separate Weinkarte hier allerdings nur
vier Weine in der First Class konnte ich
mir zehn Weine aussuchen los ging es
dann mit dem leckeren Bier aus Singapur
und ein paar Nüssen und so sah dann
meine Vorspeise aus ein bisschen Salat
dazu diese wirklich leckeren Shrimps
Alternative hätte ich noch eine Suppe
bestellen können oder einfach so ein
bisschen traditionellen arabischen Humus
habe mich dann aber für die Shrimps
entschieden und das war denke ich kein
Fehler also die haben echt super super
gut geschmeckt auch der Salat nice super
frisch gutes Dressing dazu gab's noch
einige verschied ene Brotsorten also
Vorspeise auf jeden Fall wie in jedem
anderen guten Restaurant dann ging's
auch schon weiter mit dem Hauptgang das
geht echt flott in der Business Class in
der First Class kann man ja alles essen
wann man will zu welcher Uhrzeit wie
viel man will und so weiter und in der
Business Class gibt's ja eine feste
Reihenfolge ich habe mich dann für das
Rinderfilet mit Bohnen und
kartoffelgrateng entschieden war soweit
gut hat mich aber nicht komplett
umgehauen ähnlich wie auf dem Hinflug in
der First Class da war alles top nur das
Fleisch geht halt besser ich weiß jetzt
nicht woran es liegt bei Qatar Airways
hat mir das Beef auf jeden Fall besser
geschmeckt aber nicht zu vergessen wir
sind natürlich auch in dem Flug Zeug da
sollten die Erwartungen auch nicht allzu
hoch sein natürlich wenn man so viel
Geld zahlt das war aber auch das einzige
was mich ein bisschen enttäuscht hat
alternativ hätte ich auch chicken oder
Lachs bestellen können als Hauptgang
oder sogar auch was
vegetarisches und dann ging es aber auch
schon weiter mit dem Nachtisch habe ich
mich einfach für so eine obstplatte
entschieden Honigmelone Erdbeeren
Brombeeren renfrucht da war echt vieles
dabei hatte ich irgendwie Bock drauf
auch wenn ich sonst lieber wirklich so
Schokolade oder irgendwie was
schokoladiges als nachch esse der
obsteller war auf jeden Fall nicht
verkehrt also Essen wirklich gut am Ende
hört ihr noch mein Fazit und dann auch
den Vergleich zu Qatar Airways ein
bisschen genauer erläutert als bes class
Passagier bekommt man auch eine
Schlafmaske ich glaube in der economie
auch bin ich mir jetzt gerade gar nicht
so sicher und noch ein Paar Strümpfe ich
habe mich dann erstmal ein bisschen
hingelegt konnte allerdings nicht so gut
pennen es war auch richtig turbulent als
wir dann so gerade in den europäischen
Luftraum kam dann habe ich mir noch ein
Cappuccino reingehauen um wieder ein
bisschen wach zu werden und da meine
airpods leer waren habe ich dann über
die Kopfhörer von Emir rides so ein paar
alte Hits aus 2009 gehört ihr könnt ja
mal raten was das hier für ein Song war
man sich echt das schon so lange her ist
14 Jahre einfach ich dachte das sieht
was SPW von 2015 oder so aufgrund des
Gewitters in Dubai was wirklich sehr
sehr selten vorkommt hatten wir eine
gute Stunde Verspätung und dann ging es
aber nach 6 sch in der Luft auch langsam
los mit dem landeranflug auf
[Musik]
Frankfurt auf jeden Fall landen wir
sofort ging mal wieder richtig schnell
[Musik]
um
bye bye
hier okay wieder zurück in Frankfurt ich
muss sagen das ist echt wirklich
entspann gut auf der erste der
aussteigen durfte man ist halt wirklich
super schnell aus dem Flieger auch weil
so viel Platz ist da entsteht nicht so
viel Trubel das ist schon geil also das
war jetzt vielleicht 3 Minuten und zack
[Musik]
draußen Leute ich habe gerade 5,29€ für
dieses Red Bull bezahlt WTF wo leben wir
also so 3,29 € okay aber
diger so Leute mittlerweile wieder zu
Hause ich habe ein bisschen um baut
bisschen weit weg die Frage die ich mir
noch gestellt habe welche ist denn jetzt
die beste Business Class der Welt ich
sag mal so ich habe ja jetzt erst zwei
getestet einmal Emirates und Qatar man
muss sagen Service und Essen bei beiden
Airlines wirklich phänomenal Weltklasse
die Flugbegleiter sind super nett und
einem wird eigentlich jeder Wunsch von
den Lippen abgelesen also man merkt
wirklich dass die richtig darauf
geschult sind es ist ja auch so wenn du
Flugbegleiter in der Business Class
werden willst musst du erst economy
machen irgendwann kannst du ein bises
machen und irgendwann eventuell auch
first das hat mir der Simon auf dem
Hinflug in der First Class erzählt wie
das so abläuft und ich denke ihr habt's
gemerkt ich habe mich in der Emirates BU
class super wohl gefühlt einen topflug
wie damals auch bei Qatar einfach ein
Erlebnis und wenn man da jetzt irgendwas
vergleicht ist es natürlich Meckern auf
sehr sehr hohem Niveau wir haben aber
schon kleine Unterschiede und zwar habe
ich bei Qatar ja einige Vorspeisen
bekommen bei Emirates konnte ich mir nur
eine aussuchen der Umfang des
essensmenüs bei Qatar war einfach noch
größer und ich würde auch sagen das
Essen war ein klein Ticken besser meern
auf hohem Niveau wie gesagt was mir auch
noch aufgefallen ist ich habe keinen
Schlafanzug bekommen und bei Qatar habe
ich zweimal also ich bin ja einmal auch
umgestiegen einen Schlafanzug bekommen
brauche ich nicht aber ist ja schon ein
kleiner Unterschied und diese Qatar
Airways Q Suite die eigentlich ist wie
einen First Class Erlebnis bei anderen
Airlines man kann seinen eigenen Abteil
quasi abschließen das ist wirklich schon
unschlagbar und gibt es soweit ich weiß
n noch einmal bei allen nipon Airways
habe ich mir gerade zufällig im Internet
so ein flight Report angeschaut also das
ist auch ganz interessant soll wohl auch
eine richtig gute Airline sein ich muss
ganz klar sagen mein Platz ein der
besten bsinessg der Welt behält Qatar
Airways bei Emirates auch super geil
aber nicht ganz so gut ich ich weiß ich
bin in der Boeing 777 geflogen im airbis
A380 sieht das Ganze vielleicht doch mal
ein bisschen anders und besser aus werde
ich sicherlich irgendwann auch mal
testen ansonsten mache ich mich weiter
auf die Spuren wir werden natürlich auch
noch Singapore Airlines Business Class
testen meinwen auch dies All Nippon
Japan Airways soll richtig gut sein ich
weiß gerade gar nicht ob es Japan
Airlines oder Airways heißt na ja
airfance soll auch nicht verkehrt sein
also ich bin mal gespannt ich werde mir
so nach und nach mein eigenes Business
Class Ranking bauen jetzt ist Katar auf
1 Emirat auf 2 wir werden mal schauen
was noch kommt ich hoffe das Video hat
euch gefallen lasst mir sehr gerne
Däumchen nach oben da abonniert den
Kanal für weitere solcheer Videos da
wird auf jeden Fall noch einiges geiles
kommen wir sehen uns heute haut rein
ciao